I lied I was
lying hi everyone I'm Augustus PR and I
play Adam Ellis in dear David and I'm
Andre bang and I play Evelyn today we're
going to play a little game called two
truths and a
lie we're going to say three things two
of them are true one of them's a lie and
then and then we get to each ask two
questions but never three cuz when you
ask three we get to murder each other
live on
BuzzFeed only two
questions never
three
why asking yourself Augustus pu has
never seen Harry Potter is a Virgo
played a superhero named ass kicker
question name five characters in Harry
Potter Luna love good Harry Potter Ron
Weasley
herione had grid
I choose that one you didn't watch Harry
Potter everyone's seen Harry Potter
obviously what's a lie oh I said I've
never seen her oh I read it
wrong I got it yeah you get that
point I'm ready to detect your lies I
have bungee
jumped I don't like chocolate mhm or my
first job was at a lottery center where
did your bunny jump Whistler have I seen
you eat chocolate on this whole Sho a
damn it God she's good she's good I'll
give her that she's really good Final
Answer C see you didn't you didn't
that's not been your first job it is
isn't it it was oh God which one is it
then it's the I can't I don't like
chocolate that's the LIE oh can't stand
cuz you do like I confused I got
confused I did the wrong I did the a
double negative yeah are you ready mhm
Augustus pu that's me has a tattoo mhm
of his family's initial
played his first TV role at the age of
mhm has two dogs what's the name of your
third dog I only have two
dogs would you like the name of my two
dogs yeah cheich and Chong where is your
tattoo that's a third question all right
we move on to the murder round what was
the second question I gave you the names
of both the dogs I've only got one dog
come on yeah I even said I lied I was
lying
good excellent one point to me okay I'm
ready I'm ready to decipher truth I
finished a mini Triathlon I backpacked
in Australia okay and I don't drink
coffee you did not do a triathlon why do
you say really where did you do triathon
where did I do it yeah where did you do
it I did it in BC I can't remember where
it's a she's lying is that your final
answer yeah no it's backpacked I hav't
backpacked in Australia Oh I thought
that one was real yeah a has lived in a
haunted house B loves skydiving C middle
name is Art when you've Sky dived how
did you feel when you got to the floor I
loved it it's my favorite thing to do
where does your middle name come from
art family name short for arur I think
your skydiving is a lie you think I
don't like skydiving yeah I don't I hate
it I did it once and I vomited for 3
days I hate it
I am right-handed mhm I a Taurus mhm I
have a degree in Psychology where did
you do a degree uh
UBC seems to be your answer for
everything y I don't think you have a
degree in
Psychology I think that's a lie do you
you have a final answer
yeah I do come on what do you actually
yeah oh that's so interesting so which
one's the line then the middle one I'm
not right-handed I'm left-handed oh yeah
yeah oh I could have known that so
Andrea won I'm not happy about it watch
dear David stop looking at me
[Music]
done